how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
yesterday some very very interesting
information was discovered about tony
stark
bruce banner and avengers end game
specifically in regards to
time travel now obviously time travel
was a
huge part to avengers end game not only
using time travel to go back in time
get the stones and bring everybody back
but another big part was also
figuring out how time travel works the
avengers tried to do it on their own
with the hulk
captain america and black widow and of
course scott lang
oh hi hi uh is anyone home this is uh
scott
but ultimately it was tony stark that
figured out how exactly to
navigate time travel and that's actually
a very important element because there
are consequences to time travel as tony
stark states
and as it turns out as it's been
recently revealed tony stark knew
a lot more about time travel and the
consequences that he led on to in
avengers end game and he even talked to
bruce banner about these a little bit so
we'll talk about how it's revealed that
tony stark knew
that traveling back in time could create
different realities
and how kang the conqueror and avengers
secret wars was set up in avengers end
game
and we'll talk about the recently
revealed and very important information
that tony stark new in avengers inn game
in a new article from sci-fi they show
us a new excerpt from a recently
released book
called the wakanda files which is an in
canon book
meaning whatever they talk about in the
book any events that take place
actually happen within the marvel
cinematic universe even if we haven't
seen them on screen
and in this article they talk about a
very specific part of this book an
encrypted
text that tony stark sent to bruce
banner sharing their findings on
time-space
gps that they teamed up to create in
avengers in game
before the living avengers pull their
time travel plan completely together
tony uses david dutch's model of quantum
mechanics
and sent this message to bruce banner
altering events of the past
could never affect the continuous loop
though
it could create tangential split
timelines
let's not worry about that for the time
being right
question mark one reality at a time for
all our sanity
now this is very very big news because
it shows that tony stark
knew the consequences and the risk of
time travel creating alternate timelines
tony stark is one of the smartest people
in the marvel cinematic universe on
earth
and he was clearly thinking about every
single possible scenario of what they
were going to do with their so-called
time heist
and of course he came to the conclusion
that what they were about to do
could affect the other universes
creating different timelines and
alternate realities this
is even more apparent that tony stark
knew this when you look at the scene
with him and captain america right after
thanos attacks the avengers compound and
tony gives captain back his shield he
tells captain america
you mess with time it tends to mess back
now a lot of people have been wondering
what is this specifically referring to
and while of course it is immediately
referring to thanos there is a lot more
to it than that
as with most time travel movies there
are consequences to going back in time
and altering it
but all of those movies don't exist
within a larger universe where all of
the films are interconnected
avengers in-game however exists in the
mcu
where one thing affects everything and
we 100 know that avengers in game did
create
alternate timelines and other universes
and this is where time starts to mess
back the avengers went back in multiple
points in time
and although some timelines may have
been cleared up by captain america
returning the infinity stones
there were still other timelines created
loki created one when he escaped with
the tesseract which of course
is the space stone and he'll probably
hop around into other universes as well
2014's timeline was changed and a
different one created when thanos from
2014 came to the present time and of
course no doubt we'll learn about more
created
but now what we have is a bunch of
different universes with different
paths but the avengers and other
characters the same ones from our
universe
now exist in other universes going down
different paths and as i mentioned
before this leads to two things
kang and avengers secret wars battle
world
kang is the master of time the time
travel king and it's pretty much all but
confirmed that he's going to be
appearing in ant-man 3.
and it's widely assumed that jonathan
majors is going to be playing kang
since he's been cast for a role in the
movie now through the comics king has
traveled through
various different timelines conquering
them all hence his name kang the
conqueror
and now the avengers have messed with
and altered other timelines
and this is bad news for our heroes
because kang the conqueror the master of
time travel probably doesn't like people
messing with his timelines
and not to mention he probably doesn't
like other people figuring out time
travel as well
as most villains want everything to
themselves kang is probably no exception
and much like in the comics kang will
most likely want to destroy
the avengers and of course the fantastic
four once they enter the mcu
but this is why king the conqueror is
going to be one of the next big bad
villains of the mcu
but ultimately all of this is going to
come full
circle from avengers and game to
avengers secret wars
throughout marvel's phase 4 marvel's
phase 5 and marvel's phase 6
we are going to see the repercussions of
the avengers going back in time and
changing some events of the past and
creating alternate universes
the mcu will explore this in many
different areas such as
the loki series which is also seemingly
going to set up kang
and avengers secret wars as well it's
already been confirmed that the tva the
time
variants authority is going to be in the
loki series
now their primary job is to police
different
universes to make sure one universe or
somebody
from one universe does not affect or
threaten
another universe and they have had
run-ins with kang and the comics
although they have never actually been
able to defeat him
however the tva only steps in when
universes are being threatened
and since the tva is going to be in the
loki series that means some universes
are being threatened and probably at
first
just by loki because after all him
escaping with the tesseract did create
an
alternate timeline and he's the god of
mischief so he's bound to get into some
trouble
but this is where it starts different
universes being created
and explored until eventually years and
years down the road in the next avengers
in-game level event avengers secret wars
they all come together
you see the whole premise of battle
world is that the multiverse kind of
gets destroyed
then the fragments of all of these
different destroyed
universes all come together into one
universe
all contained on one planet battle world
the involvement of the time variance
authority
and the knowledge and warning that tony
stark gave us
about different realities and universes
being affected ultimately leads us to
the fact that all of these new universes
being created
isn't a very good thing and if one
universe or a couple of different
universes get too dangerous they could
affect and perhaps even eventually
destroy
other universes which is what many
people expect to see
over the years in the marvel cinematic
universe exploring different realities
exploring different universes
exploring the organization that is
responsible for keeping these universes
apart
to eventually see it all fall apart and
then collide
to form battle world where we'll get
multiple versions of different
characters
we'll see different versions of iron man
captain america the scarlet witch
the hulk etc and of course not to
mention the x-men and the fantastic four
are involved with secret wars as well so
it appears to be that tony stark
kind of foresaw this of course he
probably couldn't imagine what big of
scale it could be
but he foresaw complications with
different universes nonetheless
and he hinted at this in avengers end
game and not to mention the coincidence
that before avengers end game came out
the russo brothers did a q a and they
were asked if they would ever come back
to direct a marvel film
and they replied with if it's secret
wars and since after avengers in game
they have expressed
multiple times how they would be
interested in returning to direct secret
wars
so it seems like we definitely know what
our next avengers in game event is going
to be
and tony stark was hinting at it
happening in avengers end game
so let me know what you think about this
new discovery and setup for avengers
secret wars in the comments down below
and let me know how you think the
multiverse is going to end up in the
marvel cinematic
universe moving forward in phase 4 5 6
and beyond don't forget to subscribe to
stay up to date on all the latest news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win an
iron spider funko pop just subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you